been someone that's really been ever
since August just kind of shooting up
the basically Fantasy Football World
Devonte Parker coming off 156 yards in a
game last week Claude Edward Solaire
she's tied for 39th and Carries he's
tied for 14th and targets and yet he is
the rb3 in real life PPR points for
games Nick Chubb unfortunately trying to
play the volume game Nick Chubb just
doesn't do it for me Terry mcclorn
fantastic real life player I just don't
think he's the Undisputed number one
that we thought he was Jaguars running
back Travis etn DeAndre Swift and Travis
etn number one and number two in yards
per reception this season DK Metcalf for
the Seattle Seahawks they're moving with
more Tempo they have to pass the ball
more because their defense can't stop
anyone right now and Geno isn't terrible
Alan Robinson someone that most people
are starting to treat as a deep low wide
receiver three maybe even a wide
receiver four Josh Jacobs one of the
better running backs in the league I
think this year Justin Jefferson Jamar
Chase CD lamb Devonte Adams any of these
top wide receivers that have
unfortunately been disappointing for the
better part of the past two